Hi, I'm Dave from the Burps Channel Development team and today I'm going to talk a little bit
about the global crawl path view that is coming in Burp Suite 2023.8. So in previous versions of
Burp Suite, a common workflow that people had was to contribute information to the target tab by
using other tools in Burp. So you could use the proxy or you could run a crawl task. But once
you'd run a crawl task, all the information about the path that the crawl took around the application
were lost and they were only available to that crawl task itself. Coming in Burp Suite 2023.8,
you have the ability to run multiple crawls of the same target and have all of your crawl tasks
contribute to the global view of that target. So let's jump into Burp Suite and see how it works.
So here in Burp Suite 2023.8, I've got a crawl task of Gin and Juice Shop, which is Portswigger's
deliberately vulnerable web application. And in the target tab, I can see all of the paths that the
crawler took when I first crawled the application. However, that crawl was restricted to only allow
it to go one link deep in the application. So if I start a second crawl of the application that's
allowing it to do more actions, we'll be able to see that the crawl task will start contributing and
it will start populating the information from the previous crawl task. So even though it's an entirely
separate crawl task, it still remembers that the action it took this time matches the same one that
it saw that was possible last time. And that means that you can actually run multiple tasks with
different settings and have them all contribute to the same view of the application. This has really
powerful implications because if you can create a total view of what is possible to do on the site by
crawling it and exploring different interesting parts of the content, you can really map out an
application to its absolute fullest. In some cases, you might want to run a task and not have it
contribute to the global view though. For example, if you were playing around with different settings
and trying to get the best settings for your crawl, you might want to run a crawl in complete isolation.
So to do that, you go to the Scan Launcher and you tick the new Run Isolated Scan button.
If you run an isolated scan, you'll see that the Target tab appears for that scan as well as the
Target tab in the rest of Burp. And actually, these two things are completely isolated and they won't
contribute to each other and they won't conflict with each other. You still have the Crawl Past tab
as was available in previous versions of Burp as well as the Sitemap for that task specifically.
We're still thinking of ways in which we can improve this functionality and help you get even more out of
scans. So for now, give it a try and let us know any feedback that you have.